[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نديروا الزجاج باش نخليو والدينا ياكل في
المنزل ياكلوا مرتاحين وكل واحد يخرج
الماكله تاعه
ومع كل واحد نذوقه بعضنا
[موسيقى]
نشاركوا بعضنا في الماكله
وكل صبي من الاولاد يخرج الفطور تاعه بجنب
المنزل تاعه يديروا منطقه ينظفوها العشوه
ويحطوا فيها كل واحد يحطوا فيها من اكلات
شعبيه حتى ما يبانش الفقير من الغني حتى
الناس تخرج من المسجد عبر سبيل نجم يجي
ويذوق من هذيك من هذيك
ما يخففكمش هذا العادات والتقليل احنا
جبناها من جدودنا جدود
جدودنا البياتنا وبياتنا حنا وحنا ان شاء
الله رانا نديروا فيها الوليداتنا علاه
باه الربو الاخوه والتضامن والتلاحم بعضهم
البعض حتى يكبر يكبر الحمد لله يكبر
الانسان في قلبه الرحمه
والسكينه وكل شيء
[موسيقى]